aí vou eu
olá a todos eu sou maria
meu marido já disse várias vezes que se
calhar escusável começar assim porque
ainda vai ouvir
provavelmente a partida já sabe que eu
sou a maria não obstante eu gosto muito
dessa forma e hoje aqui no tek fará
entre 12 motos nos dispor todos nós com
vida e todos nós construímos vidas
diferentes faz muito sentido que o voto
seja eu sou maria e sul tal como todos
vós um ser humano isso tal como cada um
de vós um ser humano único e irrepetível
nós somos todos muito diferentes e esta
diversidade que caracteriza a condição
humana e que é capaz de gerar mais de
felicidade é fascinante porque nos leva
a uma imensidão de possibilidades
criativas
nós somos os únicos seja o ser humano é
único ser que é capaz de imaginar e
criar imaginação é diferente a
criatividade a imaginação entre nós
podemos ser muito imaginativos e no
entanto nunca criamos nada de
criatividade implica lugar na nossa
imaginação trazê lo cá para fora pôr em
prática e obter algo que valeu
ora não conheço mais nenhum ser vivo que
seja capaz de criar o troféu seja capaz
de compor um hino à alegria o wagyu 2011
ou seja capaz de descobrir as duas
loiras na genética como manda o fez e
achei bem animados não criou nada
tampouco as duas foram capazes de
inventar os sapatos um sapato não
inventa nada
quer dizer quando muito queria caos
machucao não só não é um produto novo
como a meu ver não é um produto vale no
e um sapato que o faz não será a um
sapato muito inteligente porque a
inteligência que trata entre agência foi
estudada ao longos dos anos mas foi no
início do século passado ou do século 20
que seria o primeiro teste para medir
pessoas em frança o governo francês
pediu a um psicólogo chamado alfa
benê para criar um teste que pudesse
prever o permitir para ver qual seria o
sucesso das crianças que tentavam descer
daquela altura e vinícius fez um teste
baseado na linguagem e matemática porque
era o que ensinava e acho que nós vamos
ver vem desde o time que foi inventado
possam industrial é o que vai ensinar
até hoje são as disciplinas consideradas
mais importantes
este teste deu origem ao conseg esq e
mais tarde um outro instrumento na
américa que permitiria para viver não só
o time de qualidade não conhece e ter
como o emprego que eventualmente iria
desempenhar e mesmo as suas vidas a sua
vida em geral as crianças com qi mas eu
vá ocorrer um lugar assim mas não
assistirá enquanto as crianças com qi
mais baixo seriam internadas
o aconselhável não ter filhos ou mesmo
proibidas de obter isto num teste de 50
minutos
olha esse é o último inteligência foram
sendo feitos na unidade sabe que as
habilidades cognitivas são quem mais
diversas do que a televisão tradicional
gagné convida nos a conhecer a sua
teoria das inteligências múltiplas
segundo o ew todos nós nascemos com uma
série de exigências e as misturas finas
entre elas a forma como vêm sendo
estimuladas pelo ambiente pela cultura
que é uma situação mais evidentes e
outras mais agressivas e nós vamos
descobrindo os nossos talentos e o nosso
caminho da felicidade
eu falo de uma exigência lingüística que
é inteligência da dos escritores e os
poetas shakespeare fiel brayner neruda
está em vigência musical tv tornando
john stamos amália rodrigues é
inteligência hoje quando tiver os
matemáticos e dos cientistas é que
remédios ga aos new tentemos a
inteligência especial dos artistas
plásticos nos engenheiros e arquitetos
não existiria a sagrada família não
existiria monalisa apontar rápido assim
esta exigência não existisse os jogos
olímpicos e o senhor pode chorar e
também investir em ações de inteligência
ssinte tese que tenha a ver com o corpo
pois temos a exigência interpessoal dos
professores e dos fisioterapeutas temos
a inteligência intrapessoal tv com o
conhecimento de si próprio e
inteligência deveria ficar em um exemplo
típico
ele não era um aluno brilhante no
entanto sua capacidade de organizar e
categorizar deu ao mundo uma teoria da
evolução
olha desde pequena aqui e dizer que há
muitas inteligências que a exigência não
é só ter boas notas na escola que a
inteligência é outra coisa
inteligência capaz de resolver problemas
de criar coisas importantes vocês não
ouvem destas coisas que chove nestas
coisas o papel do brasil na prova
ora é eu gostava muito que o nosso
sistema educativo pois a procura destes
talentos nas crianças os meios que eu
vejo aquilo que eu acho é um filme
educativo arcaico possam industrial
abriu muito muito ocupado com as metas
curriculares com os programas cada vez
mais exigentes e mais densas com as
evoluções um sistema educativo que está
centrado no coletivo no envio que ensina
os alunos a serem bons trabalhadores de
fato mas não pensa dos criativos que
estima é conformidade não o pensamento
divergente é uma ferramenta essencial
para a criatividade
nestas coisas da educação e sempre o
senhor que envolvem sempre me encontro
na véu no que respeita a este assunto e
concorda que foi quando eu diz que a
forma como o sistema de testar
organizado contraria as características
da inteligência senão vejamos a
hierarquia das disciplinas que isto
contraria o princípio da realidade da
música a dança o teatro às artes
plásticas são tão importante como a
matemática e as línguas e ciências
depois o princípio do dinamismo essa
interação dinâmica 500 inteligências
está contrariado pela divisão a
expressão está invertido minas
a música tem muito mais eficaz e tem
muita intuição e paixão
e para finalizar a distinção
aprendizagem entre outra é dentro de
cada um de nós é a aprendizagem não é um
número um score nós obtemos quando
incluímos todos os resultados num
determinado exame dentro do programa de
computador e obtemos uma percentagem a
aprendizagem não é dizermos que esta
escola teve mais de 23% na do que a
média nacional no exame x ou y
aprendizagem é cá dentro
ora se nós fôssemos todos iguais vez no
mundo da moda da mesma forma com a mesma
visibilidade às revoluções podem ser
factores iguais pois já somos sinta o
que acontece é isto
olha pra chegar a todos os alunos e
todos os alunos são únicos e
irrepetíveis para dispensar o mesmo
conteúdo é necessário que haja uma
altura eu ir lá no ensino é necessário
usar muitas formas há muitas maneiras de
ensinar retaguarda ou história quando
nós conhecemos bem o assunto podemos
escrever sou eu podemos contar vão
contar uma história podemos fazer uma
canção podemos ensiná los a fazer uma
experiência podemos fazer um jogo que
fez um debate quando o assunto é só para
explicar de uma maneira que se calhar
não é muito importante
concorda ora eu estive na escola é
obrigada eu acho que nunca fui à escola
para escola foi longa eu tenho muitos
anos esta área e ficou como sair com as
minhas filhas têm duas filhas a mais no
orçamento admitiu que está em 10 anos
quando eu saí na escola eu fui uma
criança curiosa como todas as crianças
estavam aprender como todas as crianças
foi muito bom a loura você não gostar da
escola em geral não gostar da partida
dada do ensino e os princípios que
porque não gosta do sistema educativo
não é é a mãe fez porque eu descobri
isso o meu caminho da felicidade do
homem é ele dizer descobrindo os meus
talentos e foi graças a ela que eu
descobri a música ea música foi
acompanhado ao longo da vida e foi viver
muito o esforço eo aborrecimento do
sistema educativo e hoje também o faz
para as minhas filhas entre muitas
outras crianças porque foi graças às
minhas filhas quando elas entraram na
escola que eu inventei as canções na
maioria por pra mim tudo é mais fácil
tentar
elas começaram a colocar questões sobre
a matéria da escola consegue inventar
canções pra elas o conteúdo é exatamente
o mesmo do primeiro ciclo
nós temos as horas e até agora cinco
temos os dias da semana as notas
musicais
as cores do arco íris os meses do ano
andré não sei os meses do ano os de tons
assim votou no akp palavra mágica
aí falei agora que os números das
dezenas e centenas o para limpar essas
opressões e os problemas
este vídeo é a cabeça que era guarda o
sistema solar a lateralidade os vários
aparelhos do corpo humano
os novos coletivos canção em sua
biografia
temos nem além das muitas delas ainda
não não foram evitadas porque como a
escola continua hesitante afegãs
musicais os rios os carros nas ilhas
portuguesas para as minhas filhas não
espero vir a evitá las em breve a
atenção do crai claro e educação porque
conhecia fica sempre vai para o time com
um futuro fantástico dos professores e
dos que os candidatos realmente é mais
fácil chegar aos alunos com estas formas
por motivos até a mesma forma que ele
feche com as melhorias estão em reforma
do livro com discos que está em as
canções com a matéria existe em forma de
v com vídeos em animação que ilustram as
pensões e também em concertos onde para
além de muita música a inspeção ea
muitas vezes e há muitas alegrias
ora os seus dizem que é mais fácil é
mais rápido que sobra tempo para fazer
outras coisas que chegam muitas crianças
não conseguiu buscar outra forma e isto
cria um incentivo para criar outras
ferramentas
os pais dizem preferir falar com os
filhos desta forma e tem mais tempo de
brincar comércio e os alunos as crianças
dizem que conseguem responder a estas
conseguem responder a exames que tenta
nas aulas que sentem mais à vontade
alguns até dizem que já não tenha virar
o quadro
eu sei que música facilitar a linguagem
e matemática
mas a música é importante que toda a
partida não estava a par das crianças
que não são tocadas de outra forma e
como a música é também a dança o
desporto
o teatro histórias ea fantasia às artes
plásticas experiências os jogos
o cinema ambição as viagens os boatos é
de centrar todas essas coisas nos dão
energia todas essas coisas que criam
entusiasmo e todas essas coisas melhoram
as nossas capacidades estimula o
pensamento vigente mas também o
pensamento lógico dedutivo estimulam a
imaginação ea criatividade que eu
gostava era que os nossos governos
pudessem na imaginação e crítica que
está em e te arriscas ante construir o
sistema executivo que vai enfrentar na
cidade de realização dos programas e das
avaliações existissem no ensino e na
aprendizagem para o ensino e
aprendizagem entre o professor eo aluno
e um professor dedicado e apaixonado não
gosta das avaliações não gosta das metas
de reciclagem essa opção gosto assim
chegar a um grupo de cerca de trazer pra
fora levar a descobrir seus talentos é
muito importante nós escolhemos os
nossos talentos porque há muita gente
que passa pela escola sem saber porquê
porque que tem jeito vamos que não tem
jeito nada porque as coisas que tenham
talento eram foram na escola
negligenciadas foram verificadas até
foram proibidas entre nós fazemos o que
gostamos porque quando fazemos o que
gostamos e queremos dormir
queremos comer o tempo passar nós
mandamos por eu tento a sessão nos
cansamos - quanto mais cansados que
temos de ser os temas situações temos
momentos de saturação
como tudo nós somos muito mais feliz
quando fazemos o que gostamos é
importante porque nós fazemos o que
temos durante muito tempo quando nós que
fazemos o que gostamos não dizemos que
fazemos que somos um professor não disse
eu faço professor e disse eu sou
professor e portanto para que isto seja
possível é preciso arriscar quanto
desconstruir
nós passamos muito tempo a trabalhar
nossas crianças também quem tem filho
vai levantar o braço tem quem tem ficha
é que esteja na tijuca escola neste
momento já tenham passado pela escola
quantas horas passamos nossas crianças
na escola podia mais ou menos 78 9 horas
depois ainda o tempo de transporte
escola não fica na escola porque ela vai
se casar aos tudo é muito tempo que é
por ser um tempo com mais prazer e muito
menos aborrecimento mas para isso é
preciso subir pra cima da cama era
evitar qualquer ato marcante e
arriscados construir e é preciso fazê lo
com alegria com amor e com dedicação
porque não há necessidade das nossas
crianças e as nossas crianças são únicas
e repetitivas
ora é a filha mais velha que estava a
viver morena chegou após o primeiro dia
de escola entra agora o 5º ano ea
primeira coisa que disse foi sabe o que
é perder no quadro de honra
e se eu tiver muito boas notas e muito
bom comportamento córdoba não pode
terminar de ver isso com a minha honra
mas aquilo que eu faço tudo o que o povo
vá se calhar o que eu disse foi que
admitiu entretanto o quadro ficou assim
lá que é muito importante o quarto
tenhamos mais importante é que eu
aprenda que gosta do que faz aprender
que gosta de testar a forma como faz
aprender e conquistar na escola seja às
vezes ficam mais importante também mas
não é
se calhar é aquilo que o critério mais
importante durante este ano
ora antes de vir para cima que protege a
esfera
elas perguntaram na teoria mas não
porque se tratava explicar e é ele quem
sabe o que me falar e explicar estas
coisas as exigências múltiplas e 16
também gostava muito de fazer uma escola
em escola seria uma escola onde houve
esta disciplina que ela está em
matemática as línguas chance a história
geografia serão dadas toda a manhã não
só da forma como elas dão mas também com
jogos e com duarte com insinuações e
depois a tarefa só haveria antiguidades
lúdicas atividades esportivas e
atividades artísticas e que os havia o
meu marido pai delas que estava com o
cinto muito grande quando houvesse muita
dureza e muito espaço para todos os
esportes claro que minha irmã vieram
logo eu quero essa escola toda a gente
que ele presta escola
então como é que se somaria à escola e
manon disse mais que nele se é são
pessoas especiais e diz assim se não
somos todos felizes eu tava atuações que
o fizeram não
com tantas coisas pode ser o arco-íris
colaborar crise e o disco ela tem mais
currículo arco-íris ela então pela
guarnição então em que ficamos ela somos
todos felizes
para lá do arco íris não serão nunca
vendi intenso é ou não é mesmo assim e
fomos transferidos para lá do arco íris
e na teoria sem conseguir o primeiro
tempo eles são sites isto que a gente
descobre que o que é que passos faz
aquilo que pais nunca desista se não lhe
as voltas e acabamos não descobre quem é
que não exista e ela lembra se o quadro
de honra que era mais fácil de pagar
eles os pecados a um padre pedófilo é
poder levar esquadros dunga burro aqui
eu tenho certeza as indulgências mais em
créditos através de exames chamaram o
quadro dos talentos
então seria o quadro das histórias o
quadro vasculares o quadro dos problemas
resolvidos e experiências fascinantes
o quadro não há formas erradas desenhar
o quadro olímpico o quadro vai amenizar
o quadro quem sou eu sou eu e o quadro
da organização
o eletricista e também queria ir para a
escola e ela ia meter desde então disse
que estava à espera
escreve escreve que a contar lá no hotel
e escrever
estou com tarde no tempo ora o serviço
está há 30 anos
a imensa os oradores todos com idéias
divergentes todos com vontade de mudar o
mundo
são muitos são muitas as pessoas que
resistiram são muitas as pessoas que
assistem através da internet que tem as
mesmas ideias que têm idéias parecidas
ora se realmente todos temos estado em
contato tão grande de mudar que estamos
à espera das ruas é esta que estão
convidados a pensar nela vive a gente
mente e dez filhos também um vídeo as
causas da avaria com esse bicho de sete
cabeças que é tabuada neste caso é um
bicho de sete oito e nove cabeças é um
rápido qual eu gosto muito e que é que
está em graça que tem precisamente
porque é feito pela média 11 e pela mas
não muito obrigada
i love rock não venceu oito vezes nova
chanca sharm el sheikh onde está dando
certo aqui não tinha confessado sua
gestão mas também só tentava aprender
mas sérgio
é verdade que chocam que torce pra cada
momento importante sem pensar no futuro
é em óbidos tempo essa opção porque é
propriedade da fifa
treinar mas arranjar uma fala que estão
na agenda pró para quem não respeitar
nossa surpresa porto 10 set
eu já faço
do outro carro que bateu perto de si não
teve trechos
o chef joca tenta assinala 30
espero até deu certo afinal é receber 60
ea confusão de substituição das plantas
do tj falta aprender
machete não é interessante
os dois deixaram sangue
casa ordem do facão sempre lá
essa opção treinada por falta de vagas
é melhor cada turma nos campeonatos que
disputar buscamos todas as portas e
brincar hoje 8 péssimas
ae
ai quem eu já te dou tchau tailândia
o sexo vaginal da prefeitura previa
confusão antes das provas planta só
falta aprender mas se julga interessante
a hitachi chefes ao cantor se trancar na
rua cantando sempre lá não é
isso resolve não é tudo
a ativa vamos repensar
aqui era
o que eu vi já feita do lado do méxico
na costa verde na época todos 2127
sempre que sem saber suas coisas e da
xuxa corinthinas e 30 que evitar chutes
na 113 sul também fechou agora trabalham
824 a prefeita deixou 46 e 48
passageiros antes de empatar fora joão
mió combinar vista de orelhas pois te
vai ficar 69 32 e 80 e pra falar muito
da isi melhor agora e não dói
quem sabe tudo da escola 55 alexandre
chieppe sábado 29 90
r7 o original parecem serviços e cria
confusão juntas todas vocês acham que
falta primeiro acho que é um momento
interessante todo o estado - 12 buchas
santa clara centro casa ordem de chatham
já cheguei lá o irã e deixei passar
obrigada